um so i'm going to talk about um
determining polynomials and the
principle minor map um so this will be
on the more pure math uh end of the
spectrum of
of this conference um but hopefully it's
it's interesting for this crowd because
of the connection with determinable
point processes which we heard about
uh on wednesday um so this will be
this is based on sort of ongoing work
with my student abir al-ahmadiyah
who just started at university of
washington
um so the the main object the main
object of the day
is the image of the principle minor map
this is going to be a map that takes an
n by n real symmetric matrix
um and just writes down the
length 2 to the n vector of all of its
principal minors
and so to every so to every subset of 1
through n
i can pick out the minor of that matrix
corresponding to i take
that collection of rows and that
collection of columns
um and then take the determinant of the
resulting principal submatrix i get i do
this with all possible subsets of one
through n
um and write down write down this vector
um and so the goal the goal for the day
is to
to cut out the image of this map
of this of the entire space of real
symmetric matrices under this map
using polynomial equations and
inequalities
and so just to start with a very small
warm-up
we could look at what happens if we look
at
two by two matrices we'll start very
small
um so i have a the input is going to be
a two by two symmetric matrix
um i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
send this to a vector of length 4 that
records all of its principal
principal minors so the empty set the
singletons
and the full subset and what is this
going to be i'm going to define the
minor of corresponding to the empty
subset as just one
the principal one by one minors
are just the diagonal elements and then
the um the element corresponding the
full subset is the determinant so
8 1 8 2 2 minus a 1
2 squared um
and if i'm handed a vector of length 4
i can i can ask when is it in the image
of this map
so in this case the image of this map
is the set of vectors so i always have
one in the first coordinate
a1 e2 a12
um and the only thing that i need is
that
the the product of the two singletons is
greater than or equal to
the whole determinant
um and if i have this then
i can i can pretty easy so it's easy to
see that this holds and if this holds i
can reconstruct the matrix
the the diagonal elements are just
given to me so i can that's pretty easy
and then for the off diagonal element i
have
plus or minus the square root of the
non-negative number i get
by taking this difference
so in particular it's not always unique
um
but if this inequality holds i then i'm
in the image of this map
um so this is an object of classical
study and sort of there was renewed
interest
in the past couple decades um
in particular so there's a paper in 2006
by olgo holtz and
and bernstein files that studied some of
the the properties of this
this map um so in particular the the
image is
a closed semi-algebraic subset of r to
the two to the n
um its dimension is is exactly the
dimension of
uh the space of real symmetric matrices
which is n plus one choose two
and the sort of less trivial properties
is invariant under various group actions
um so it's invariant under a fairly
natural action of
the symmetric group if i permute around
the
if i let the symmetric group act on the
subsets
in the natural way on the subsets of of
one through n and i
start with a vector in the image image
of this map
and i act on it then the image is also
in the
uh the in the image of the principal
minor map
um and i can see this just by permuting
you know rows and columns simultaneously
uh slightly harder to see is that it's
actually also invariant under an action
of the special linear of n copies of
the the special linear group of two by
two matrices
two by two matrices of determinant one
um
and i that's uh i will
will believe for the reader to discover
um
and so with okay so this is some of the
properties of this
this image and we want more of them um
so we already did n equals two
um let's think about n equals three the
image of the
three by three real symmetric matrices
in r8
um so the dimension of this image
the dimension of this image
if n is 3 then this is 4
choose 2 which is 6.
um and it it lives in sort of naturally
lives in the hyper
plane a sub empty set equals one
um and this is all living inside of
r to the eight um
and so what in addition to the equation
a empty set equals one
one would expect this has this has
co-dimension one
um inside of this plane so one would
expect that there's some equation
that that vanishes um
on this image and in this paper in 2006
they
they find this equation um
so here's and it's all of its glory um
so they they show that if um
if a length eight vector is the
principal minors
of a three by three symmetric matrix
then the following somewhat large uh
polynomial equation holds on the the 8
entries of this
this vector there's a degree 4
polynomial and 8 variables
and this uh
this large
large-ish beautiful polynomial
this is a classical object this is known
as the
the hyperdeterminant so i'll denote this
as hype debt
of this vector a sub s um
and this goes back to kaylee this is
known as
kaylee's hyperdeterminant
uh of
of a two by two by two tensor
um and it turns out that for n equals 3
this is this is exactly what you get
this is the relevant equation
to test whether or not you have the
principal minors of a of a 3 by 3
symmetric matrix um
now for for higher
n um what we can do is we have this
equation
and we can act under it using this group
action so we can start permuting
permuting one through and around and we
can also
act by these n copies of the special
linear group
these will act on this this polynomial
and give us not one but many a whole orb
or that's worth of polynomial equations
that have to hold
um
[Music]
and and in this paper uh burned and olga
conjecture that this
these are sort of enough to characterize
the image
um and this was something that was
proven some years later by luke oding
in 2011 so he showed that
over c if you work over the complex
numbers then you have
a a length two to the n vector is
in the image uh of this map at least up
to scaling
um if and only if it satisfies
the height this hyperdeterminant the
equation
um and its image
under sort of this full symmetry group
of n copies of sl2 and and the symmetric
um and it's just worth noting that if
you want to
you know so if we like real matrices and
we want to
consider consider real matrices instead
um if you know that your um
your vector actually comes from some
matrix
uh then you can just use these these
inequalities
to guarantee that the matrix is actually
real
okay um so that's sort of what was known
uh previously um and what i'm gonna do
is i want to talk
um about a new proof of this
that sort of goes through so many many
of the familiar objects of
from the geometry of polynomials um so i
should say luke's proof
goes through some sort of hardcore
representation theory
um and
and so what i want to talk about now
will be will be fairly uh elementary by
comparison
um with the benefit that it's also uh
fairly explicit and hopefully can be
useful
um if people want to derive sort of more
facts about
about the image of this map okay
so what i want to talk about today is
understanding
this story through the lens
of representations of multi-atlanta
polynomial
um so if we had a
if we had an n by n matrix a symmetric
matrix
um then what i'm going to do to record
its principle minors is i'm actually
going to
write down the polynomial that i get in
variables x1 through xn
by taking this matrix adding the
diagonal matrix of the variables
and then taking the determinant of this
whole thing
um and if we do this um
and you actually expand the thing out
uh then what you're going to get is
you're going to get a multi-alpha
polynomial
every variable will have degree at most
one
in particular the monomials are going to
correspond to subsets of 1 through n
and in fact they're exactly going to be
the principal minors
of this matrix and the principle minor
corresponding to a subset s
is going to show up as the coefficient
of sort of the complementary
monomial imagine if you pick off the
coefficient of just x1 then you're going
to get
the the minor corresponding to the
subset of everything else
and again just to do
an example n equals two
so we're on the same page if i took
the determinant of my two by two matrix
with the diagonal of x's added
um then i'm bringing it four terms and
they're gonna the coefficients are going
to be exactly the principal minor so i'm
gonna get x1 x2
with coefficient one just a one one x
two
plus a two two x one plus the
determinant
and so in some sense this this question
of
uh characterizing the image of this
principle minor map um
could be rephrased as characterizing um
what multi-alpha and polynomials that
look like thus come from come from
determine
it can be written in this form
and so in some sense this is one of the
themes of the workshop has been you know
stable polynomials or a generalization
of determinants in many ways
and then you know we've seen many times
further generalizations of stable
polynomials um in this workshop so this
is in some sense going backwards we're
trying to
ask what you know how do we characterize
the most restrictive
of you know our favorite classes of
polynomial
um one nice thing about this polynomial
phrase
phrasing of the problem is that the the
group actions are
are fairly easy to define if i have a
multi-affine polynomial then the
symmetric groups are
x on it by just permuting around the
variables
um and the
the special linear group acts on it
by fractional linear transformations on
the variable so if i have f
is a fractional linear transformation
and i let it act on the
sorry f is a multi-efficient polynomial
and i let it act
by an element of of sl2
on the first coordinate then i can see
this is replacing x1
by ax1 plus b over cx1 plus d and then
clearing denominators and what i'll get
is again a multi-alpha
and the claim is that this preserves
up to scaling having a determinant
representation
okay and one of the
useful ways is to to understand
polynomials like this is
by something called rayleigh differences
uh which i think we've seen
several times so if i have um
a multi-amplified polynomial f and i
pick two
indices um i can look at its rayleigh
difference
which i'm going to define with respect
to i and j is i'm going to define as
multiplying the derivative with respect
to x i times the derivative with respect
to x j
minus f times the derivative of the
effect of both
um if i start out with something that
with degree at most one in each variable
then it's not too hard to see that this
polynomial is going to have
degree at most two in each variable
and then the other thing that happens is
that
if you start with something
multi-offering then everything involving
the two variables x i and xj gets killed
and so what we end up with is a
multi-quadratic polynomial
in the remaining variables so this says
every variable degree at most two
in each
and just to be explicit so for example
we took f to be an elementary symmetric
polynomial
a small elementary symmetric polynomial
and maybe we'd pick
one and two so what do we do is we take
the derivative with respect to x one
which is just x two plus x three
multiply it by the derivative with
respect to x two which is x one plus x
three
subtract off f which i won't rewrite and
times the derivative with respect
to both which is just one um and you can
check that this ends up being
just x3 squared the only term that
survives
so degree two polynomial in the
remaining
one variable
um so one of the
one of the big theorems um
in this area is that you can use these
polynomials to actually characterize
stability of multi-alpha and polynomials
um so peter brendan showed that you have
a multi-alpha and polynomial is stable
if and only if
all these polynomials are globally
non-negative
um in particular this was useful for you
know showing negative dependence if you
want to evaluate at the
point all of all ones
um so mario
kumar daniel ploman and i had also
looked at these these polynomials
in order to characterize uh
when a multi-alpha polynomial is
determinantal
um so in particular if it's
determinantal then it's stable
um and so what we showed back
several years ago was that it's
determinable if and only if
um the israeli differences are are
perfect squares
uh in in the polynomial right so some
other polynomial squared
uh so in particular you know this is an
example
this elementary symmetric polynomial is
an example of of when
this um israeli difference happens to be
a square in the polynomial
okay um and just as an idea
of of why this is true if you have a
determinant
is actually a a really classical
matrix inequality called dodgson
condensation
uh one of the many reasons to to like
this is is dodgson is
um is lewis carroll who wrote wonderland
he showed the following the following
equation on minors of a matrix
is if you you have an n by n
matrix and you look at minors obtained
by
you know first removing the i throw and
ice column
you multiply that by the minor you get
by removing say the j th row and the jth
column
um and you subtract the the product of
almost uh uh
sorry of almost fall miners
by switching so you remove say the
jth row and the ith column and multiply
that by the minor you get by removing
the
jth column and the ith row then what you
get uh the difference of these two
is the the product of the n minus two by
n minus two minor
you get by removing all of those rows
and columns times the full determinant
um so in particular it was used you know
this was
this was originally used as a way of
of trying to calculate a big determinant
as some rational function in smaller
determinants
um and
and here so for
uh if f is equal to this determinant
i think yeah this holds for any two
matrices this
equality uh so this is this is
this is an equation on the minors of any
given matrix
um any gear so the two has to be the
same okay
yeah so and so but not because
yeah so if so the gray mate the gray
square is a
a given matrix and then i'm taking the
blue as i'm taking different minors of
it that is the
what the pictorial equation means
and it's true for any matrix
um yeah and
and so in particular what i'm going to
do is plug in this matrix
to to this equation um
and what you end up with
is if you know so one way of of taking
this minor where i remove the i throw a
knife column is i look at the
coefficient of x sub i um and so what i
mean i get is
if we actually write this out is i get
that this
is the derivative of f with respect to x
by
this one is the derivative of f with
respect to x
of j uh if i have a symmetric matrix
then
whatever whatever these two polynomials
are they're the same
so this is a square something squared
um and then what i get is
the coefficient of f with respect to or
sorry the
derivative of f with respect to both
and then um and f itself
and so if you move this around you get
exactly that the
rayleigh difference is a square in the
polynomial
um okay
and so what we're going to do is use
this to
to characterize the principle minor map
so just as an example
if i take if i take n equals three
um and i take a sort of general
multi-affine polynomial and three
variables
um then it's really um
is going to be a polynomial in just the
one variable x3 and it's going to have
degree
at most two so i can really or just
write this
as a univariate quadratic
um and then what does it mean for this
polynomial to be a square
uh this is you know this really means
that the discriminant of this quadratic
vanishes right that's how you tell if a
univariate
quadratic is a square um and then i also
if i want it to be a square of the reals
then i should have
you know these coefficients are
non-negative
um and then sort of the starting point
for this this project that i've been
working on with the beer is if you
if you write down uh
what these are as as functions of the
coefficients
a sub s this discriminant turns out to
be exactly this hyperdeterminant
condition that we wrote down before so
if you expand it out you get this giant
polynomial that was in in the box before
um
and these these end up being sort of the
the nice inequalities
that we had written down
and this c is something similar um
and so using this and this theorem
um sorry so and then
uh what we can do is in general in order
to
sort of rederive luke's result we can
look at this condition of if i have a
polynomial it has degree 2 in each
variable and i want to know
if it's a square a perfect square
then in fact it's enough to test
whether or not um certain restrictions
of it
are a square where i basically so
certainly if i have a polynomial as a
square i can restrict a bunch of zero
variables to zero and it's a square um
[Music]
and and basically i wanted to do this
uh while acting on it was this this
large symmetry group
i'm running out of time so maybe i will
gloss over the details on this um
but this property of being a square is
also has invariant under sort of this
large group action
um and so putting these two together
uh so putting this theorem with together
with the
the characterization um that i done with
mario and daniel
um it it gives another way of seeing
luke's result that you have um that
a vector of length two the n is in the
image of this map if and only if
the the hyperdeterminantal relations
hold
and and certain in sort of natural
inequalities hold
um so in this sense sort of the
the rayleigh differences uh are are very
natural ways of
of seeing this um
let's see
uh one of the things that we're still uh
that is still work in progress is to
to do this um to characterize the image
of other classes of matrices under the
principle minor map
um hermitian is sort of i think the most
natural for for this crowd but one could
look at
all sorts of other things um and then
maybe i'll close
uh with just um so i was
preparing this talk for this crowd i was
trying to think of
of a specific geometry of polynomial
implications
um and i can't say that this is super
well thought through
but uh i thought i would share it anyway
is
um so if we have the israeli differences
you know we pick two two elements of our
ground set
um this is this really difference is
going to be
a quadratic in some third variable
and we could expand it out at such um
if it's if f is stable um
some particular maybe if we have if we
have no
negative coefficients we think of this
as a strongly rayleigh distribution
um then this quadratic polynomial has to
be non-negative
and so in particular b squared the
middle coefficient the square of the
middle coefficient is bounded in terms
of the other two
um and if it's determinantal if it comes
from
as a determinant like this then there's
actually like quality
has to be a square um
and so in particular um if we're
if we're looking at uh sort of measures
of negative correlation
um so in particular if you if you take
these really differences
and divide by say f squared and
evaluated all one
um then you get these nice differences
right you get sort of the probability
that
i is in your set times the probability
of changing your set minus the
probability that both is in your set um
and in terms of this expansion
up here uh if we just plug in
one what we get is we get a sum of these
terms
um i should say that so in this case
this
this first term is the the rayleigh
difference of
the derivative with respect to xk
um and this last term is the
really difference of sort of its
evaluation at zero
and think of this as whether k is in
your set or not in your set
um and so in some so one possible
interpretation of
uh of this determinant condition
is that sort of given
if you fix uh you know the evaluations
of a
and c at x equals one so if you fix
the rayleigh differences of the
derivative with respect to some variable
and its restriction to zero
then
then this expression is maximized um
forward by determinant when b
squared is when b is as large as it can
be
um and so this is this is fairly
open-ended but um one of the
the questions that this in particular
left me with is um
is if there's some meaningful sense for
which
um measure strongly rarely measures
coming from determinants
are extremal um in some some interesting
um i'll leave that as an open-ended
question for the crowd um
and so i think that will that will
conclude
what i have to say um
thanks thanks for your attention
thanks a lot cynthia uh it's really nice
any any questions
so by extremely you're imagining
something like can you write strongly
really measures as mixtures of
detrimental
or something like that or um
i mean so to me this so i don't know if
it's uh
useful but here like if you if you
specified
say the the correlation
of um
say the uh what is it called
um
[Music]
uh so for example if you if you
condition on the fact that like k
is in your set or out of your set then
you get these
these two polynomials sort of the
derivative and the restriction to zero
um and if you were to
specify the
[Music]
um the amount of negative correlation
going on
for both of those um
[Music]
then to me this this equation
suggests that the terminal ones sort of
give you the
the maximal value of this difference
um that's
yeah i phrased the question purposely
vaguely because i wanted it to
lead maximize the potential you mean it
maximizes the negative correlation
is that uh
yeah the the way that it should be at
maxima
one other thing which i'm not sure if
it's related but there are these works
in
like a number of works in uh machine
learning community
which uh they
sort of try to learn a determinant of
point process
or uh you know i guess
another related one is given a
distribution you want to see how close
or far is it from and
i'm not uploading process so i thought
and i'm not sure if this
line of work is related but it seems
like this vector you're you're giving
asking if this is a
you know coming from a matrix yes
i mean it's there you know it's a length
two to the end
thing so you so it's yeah
yeah no there was this um this work of
i think really koleska and toscar
who um so
if you're given a uh if you're promised
that the
[Music]
um that you you have a matrix
and you sort of can access the principle
minors by some oracle
um then there's a
o of n cubed uh
time algorithm to actually reconstruct
some matrix with those principal minors
yeah um but you have but you sort of you
can't
check the thing actually that one i
think is very simple the thing is you
can figure out the entries on the
diagonal
and once you have that like like you
said you can just figure out any
off-diagonal entries i think you just
need n
squared even many
you need you need the cubics because
the off diagonal the sign the signs of
the off-diagonal entries are not
independent
there's some constraints on what the oh
yeah the sign problem yeah there was
some sign from
yeah um so that's so you need the the
cubic terms but um but yeah it's
it's
yeah i think you can do it for if you
know that you have such a vector i think
you can do it
fairly fairly explicitly but yeah it was
nice they also
they uh i think they did it with like n
squared um times of like accessing this
oracle
and then like n times
x uh sort of other things where s
there was uh s was like the sparsity of
the matrix the number of non-zero
hundreds in the modules
this characterization of determinant
polynomials is there any hope of
extending it to like
beyond multi-i find like maybe degree
two in each variable or something like
that
i mean israeli thing doesn't exist for
that right
it still does um the so this
um i sort of phrased everything in multi
you could still do
you could certainly still take this
polynomial um it'll no longer have
degree two in each variable
yeah um and then some of these if and
only if's
breakdown yeah that's what so that
breaks down right but is there something
nice other than
is there another snowy if that's uh um
that's a good question uh i
i don't know um
i think in general the sorts of
uh
yeah i don't know mario here mario might
know
um yeah it would be interesting to try
we haven't
um sort of looked at it for things other
than
the multi-alpha i think if you do it
arbitrary then it gets a little bit
uh
large like even now
isn't the forward direction of both of
these two at this point
yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely uh so the
the forward direction of both of these
is true
and the proof you know for the
yeah anyway the oh no sorry the this
let's be careful i don't know about the
table
not the not the not the stable
this one this one is is for sure true
yeah um yeah if you cross out
multi-alpha and then you just get an
implication
but the other one i don't know uh so
this
if you cross out this then
and this way i think you have to you
have to it's a sum of squares